on valentine's day in 1895 the most
famous playwright in the
english-speaking world oscar wilde
presented his new play the importance of
being earnest in london at st james's
theater the audience was packed with
celebrities aristocrats and famous
politicians eagerly awaiting another
triumph from a man universally heralded
as a genius at the end of the
performance there was a standing ovation
critics adored the play and so did
audiences making it wild's fourth major
success in only three years
yet only a few short months later wilde
was bankrupt and about to be imprisoned
his reputation was in tatters and his
life ruined beyond repair it was as
everyone then and now agreed
a tragedy the swift fall of a great man
due to a small but fateful slip
the story of how oscar wilde went from
celebrity playwright to prisoner in such
a short space of time has much to teach
us about disgrace and infamy
we don't have to be acclaimed to
understand that wild's poignant tragedy
urges us to abandon our normal moralism
and have sympathy for those who stray
it calls for us to extend our love not
just to those who obviously deserve it
but precisely to those who seem not to
wile's tragedy began several years
earlier when he was introduced to a
beguiling young man named lord alfred
douglas
douglas known to family and friends as
bosey was extremely handsome charming
and arrogant by 1892 a year after they'd
met the two men had fallen profoundly in
love
although wilde was married with two
children he spent much of his time with
boce they traveled together stayed in
hotels and hosted large dinners for
their friends
by 1894 the pair were constantly seen
together in public and rumors of their
love affair had spread as far as boces
father the marquis of queensberry the
marquis was a cruel aggressive character
known for inventing the queensberry
rules of amateur boxing
having decided that wilde was corrupting
his son he demanded that the pair stop
seeing each other
when wilde refused queensberry began to
hound him across london threatening
violence against restaurant hotel
managers if they allowed wilde and bosey
onto the premises queensberry booked a
seat for the opening night of the
importance of being earnest he planned
to throw a bouquet of rotting vegetables
at wild when he took to the stage
when wilde heard about the stunt he had
embard from the theater and queensberry
flew into a rage he left a calling card
which publicly accused wilde of having
sex with other men
since homosexuality was illegal and
deeply frowned upon in victorian society
this was a dangerous accusation
seeing no end to queensbury's bullying
behaviour wilde decided to take legal
action
by suing queensberry for libel wilde
hoped to clear his name and put an end
to the harassment
when the trial began wilde was confident
he took to the stand and gave witty
distracting answers during his
cross-examination within a few days
however the tide had turned against him
it became clear that queensberry's
lawyers had hired private detectives to
uncover an uncomfortable truth
that both wild and bosey had hired male
prostitutes
some had even blackmailed wild in the
past successfully extorting money from
him in return for their silence
the trial was hopeless and wild withdrew
his case but events had spiraled beyond
his control and wilde was soon arrested
on charges of gross indecency
the legal costs left him bankrupt and
theaters were forced to abandon his
plays
wile's criminal trial began at the old
bailey on april the 26th he faced 25
charges all of which surrounded his
sexual relationships with younger men
wilde continued to deny the allegations
and the jury could not reach a verdict
but when the prosecution were allowed to
try wilde a second time he was
eventually found guilty
the judge said at his sentencing it is
the worst case i have ever tried i shall
pass the severest sentence the law
allows
wilde was sentenced to two years of hard
labor
inmates in london's pentonville prison
where he was sent spent six hours a day
walking on a heavy treadmill or
untangling old rope using their hands
and knees
for someone of wild's luxurious
background it was an impossible hardship
his bed was a hard plank which made it
difficult to fall asleep prisoners were
kept alone in their cells and barred
from talking to one another
wild suffered from dysentery and became
physically very frail
after six months he was transferred to
reading jail as he stood on the central
platform of clapham junction with
handcuffs around his wrists passersby
began to recognize the celebrity
playwright they laughed and mocked some
even spat at him
for half an hour i stood there wilde
wrote afterwards in the gray november
rain surrounded by a jeering mob for a
year after that was done to me i wept
every day at the same hour and for the
same space of time
during his last year in prison wilde
wrote an anguished essay de profundis
i once a lord of language have no words
in which to express my anguish and my
shame
terrible as was what the world did to me
what i did to myself was far more
terrible still the gods had given me
almost everything but i let myself be
lured into long spells of senseless and
sensual ease i allowed pleasure to
dominate me i ended in horrible disgrace
there is only one thing for me now
absolute humility i have lain in prison
for nearly two years i have passed
through every possible mood of suffering
the only people i would care to be with
now are artists and people who have
suffered those who know what beauty is
and those who know what sorrow is
nobody else interests me
in may 1897 wilde was finally released
he set sail for dieppe in france the
very same day his wife constance had
changed her name and moved abroad with
her two sons vivian now 11 and cyril 12.
wilde would never see his children again
he missed them every day
constance agreed to send him money on
the condition that he end his
relationship with bosey but only a few
months later the pair reunited and the
money stopped
they moved to naples and wilde began
using the name sebastian melmoth
inspired by the great christian martyr
saint sebastian and a character from a
gothic novel who had sold his soul to
the devil
they hoped to find privacy abroad but
the scandal seemed to follow them
wherever they went
english patrons recognized them in
hotels and demanded that they be turned
away
after constance stopped sending money
bosey's mother offered to pay their
debts if he returned home and the pair
once again parted ways
scorned by many of his former friends
wilde moved to paris where he lived in
relative poverty he spent most of his
time and money in bars and cafes
borrowing money wherever he could and
drinking heavily his weight ballooned
and his conversation dragged he was
slowly inebriating himself to death
when a friend suggested he tried to
write another comic play he replied i
have lost the mainspring of life and art
i have pleasures and passions but the
joy of life is gone
his final piece of writing a poem the
ballad of reading jail was published in
1898 the author's name was listed as
c33 wild's cell block and cell number
from his time in the prison
towards the end of 1900 wilds had
developed meningitis and became gravely
ill
a catholic priest visited his hotel and
baptized him into the church he died the
following day age 46.
more than a century later in 2017 a law
was passed to exonerate those who had
been convicted due to their sexuality
and oscar wilde received an official
pardon from the uk government
it is hugely important declared a
government minister that we pardon
people convicted of historical sexual
offenses who would be innocent of any
crime today
our society has become generous towards
wild specific behavior but it remains
moralistic towards a huge number of
other peoples and ways of life
many of us would across the ages want to
comfort and befriend oscar wilde it's a
touching hope but one that would be best
employed in extending understanding to
all those less talented and less witty
figures who are right now facing grave
difficulties and still deserve
compassion
that would be true civilization and a
world in which wild's horrifying
downfall had not been in vain
our online shop has a range of books and
gifts that address the most important
and often neglected areas of life click
now to learn more
you